A college student recently asked me
whether students should invest in
bitcoin. I said I don't give investment
advice, but I cautioned her: Be careful
what you mean by invest! You see, crypto
currencies – or coins – aren't like stocks
that give you rights to a company. With
most coins, all you own is the right to
transfer it to someone else.
She said, "That sounds like traditional
currencies. So why does bitcoin fluctuate
in value so much?" With traditional
currencies, when people want to do more
transactions or save more, the amount of
the currency grows (if governments are
doing their job), so the value stays about
the same. Not so with cryptocurrencies!
Their supply is driven by software which
generally creates new coin at a fixed pace,
regardless of the demand for the coin. So
whenever people want more, whether for
transactions or to speculate for future
values – or just because they're
enthusiastic about coin – the value grows.
When people want less, the value drops.
It's all about demand. So with
cryptocurrencies, know what you own.
Do you think cryptocurrencies are a good
investment? Let us know your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.